mayor Royal counselor sus all make
comments where she suggested that Jewish
communities are frightened by your
divisive attitude it's been criticized
as dogist or politics I just wondered
you know how did it make you feel well I
think particularly in the context of the
last 24 hours I think the other
weaponizing Jewish people is wrong and
my
fear is we may be seen from the
conservatives a
rerun of the 2016 Memorial contest and
let me be quite clear there are Jewish
people in London londoners who have
genuine concerns and anxieties and
aspirations and we should be addressing
them not using them as a port to try and
win wordss